avec vous ce soir sylvain leduc
vice-président exécutif et directeur de
la recherche à la réserve fédérale de
san francisco
bonsoir monsieur le duc et d'histoire
vous êtes aussi un ancien de la banque
du canada n'est ce pas et vous êtes
maintenant à san francisco à la réserve
fédérale qu'est ce qui vous a amené à
les travailler du côté américain je fais
mes études à bégayer la presse nationale
et aux états unis puis j'ai commencé à
travailler à la réserve fédérale de
philadelphie bref à washington puis je
me suis ramassée à ça à san francisco
parce qu'on aimait bien la région fait
un petit détour après ça on est revenu à
la banque du canada pendant deux ans
comme sous gouverneur puis on est
retourné avec la famille à san francisco
après ce que c'est le même monde le
monde d'abord le canada et le monde la
réserve fédérale aux états unis c'est
très similaire d'une certaine façon les
beaucoup d' analyse beaucoup de
recherche qui qui sont faites dans les
deux cas la réserve fédérale est
décentralisée tandis que c'est plus
centralisé à la banque du canada je
pense qu'à la réserve fédérale il ya une
certaine il ya plus une grande latitude
de points de vue qui sont émis d'une
certaine manière parce qu'on est dans
des endroits différents et des types de
recherches qui sont fait qu'ils sont
différentes dans chaque réserve fédérale
à travers le pays est ce que vous sentez
qu'en ce moment la confiance du public
et ébranlée envers les banques centrales
compte tenu du niveau d'inflation des
hausses de taux également des
politiciens notamment au canada qui
attaquent aussi ses institutions est ce
que vous sentez que la confiance des
gens est ébranlée envers les banques
centrales parce que les cantons gardent
les données je pense que non bizarrement
les gens sont préoccupés par l'inflation
qui est trop élevé mais quand on regarde
les données les attentes d'inflation à
court terme ont augmenté par exemple
pour compenser l'inflation qu'est ce qui
va arriver l'année prochaine c'est
beaucoup plus haut mais si on regarde à
long terme c'est pas le cas les
inflations les anticipations d'inflation
presque pas bougé sur dix ans sur cinq à
son regard des marchés financiers c'est
exactement la même chose et donc je
pense que les gens savent que les
banques centrales vont faire ce qu'ils
ont à faire pour ramener l'inflation à
la cible de 2 2% les gens savent sommet
entre temps le niveau d'inflation qui
est élevé donc s concerne une forme
d'inquiétude de la part
du public face au travail des banques
centrales mais je pense qu'on veut que
les taux d'intérêt moi je pense qu'on
peut que les banques centrales fassent
ce qu'elles ont à faire pour ramener le
taux d'inflation le plus rapidement
possible vers la stabilité des prix vers
la cible de 2% que la banque du canada
où la fed non ça c'est primordial je
pense que si les banques ont les ménages
les firmes comprennent ça les gens
d'affaires comprennent ce que je pense
qu'ils comprennent on peut voir
dernièrement aux etats-unis à l'automne
quand le discours a changé quand les
perspectives d'inflation inchangé les
taux d'intérêt sont vraiment il est tout
l'intérêt à long terme les taux
hypothécaires se sont ajustés très
rapidement tout l'intérêt hypothécaire
sur 30 ans a presque doublé en quelques
mois mais quand même le taux d'inflation
est rendu est aux états unis entre 8 et
9% présentement est ce que la réserve
fédérale un peu échappé face à
l'inflation mais je pense quand on
retourne en arrière la pandémie c'est ça
c'est le problème c'est que c'est hyper
incertain on peut pas vraiment prédire
l'évolution de la pandémie sont retourne
en arrière en mars au printemps dernier
les choses s'amélioraient la pandémie
est s'estompe un peu les d'accès est
devenu disponible
les économistes réouvrait et puis là une
variante delta qui est arrivé à l'été et
puis on a on est retombé en crise un peu
aux états unis et puis sachez que ça
crée du routard les premiers avec les
l'approvisionnement les chaînes
d'approvisionnement à la production aux
états unis ce qui a tout retardé puis on
s'est retrouvé avec beaucoup plus
d'inflation qu'on croyait beaucoup plus
d'inflation qu'on croyait parce que là
les banques centrales ne l'ont pas vu
non ont manqué
dans le regard prospectif de la
possibilité de voir l'inflation partir
en courant ben parce que les prédire ce
qui se passe avec les chaînes des prix
d'approvisionnement est très très très
difficile de prédire ce qui va se passer
avec la pandémie au niveau global est
très difficile parce qu'on sait on est
impacté par ce qui se passe en chine on
ne voit en ce moment avec les cubs euros
la politique de co 2 0 en chine qui fait
que la production arrête puis c'est bien
impacter la production globale et
l'inflation ici aux etats-unis ou au
canada donc donc oui très difficile à
prédire est ce que c'est le moment le
plus difficile de gérer une banque
centrale et une politique monétaire en
ce moment il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes
en ce moment c'est très intéressant et
beaucoup d'incertitude on voit moyens
susvisé dit la guerre en scène la montée
du prix de l'essence
bien que toujours les perles la pandémie
qui crie beaucoup d'incertitudes ça
c'est un pur c'est un peu nouveau sacré
c'est beaucoup c'est très difficile de
de gérer la politique monétaire dans un
environnement aussi incertain en même
temps sur cannes seront remontés à 10
ans les grands crise financière de
2008-2009 avait beaucoup d'incertitude
ou s'il a plus d'incertitudes quant à la
cause je dirais de l'aide de la crise
tandis qu'ici en 2020 observer on savait
bon c'est la pandémie n est pas vraiment
personne qui était responsable donc je
pense que c'est c'était beaucoup plus
facile de répondre en 2020 est-ce que
les risques de récession en ce moment
sont élevés quand on regarde les données
financières qu'on regarde souvent on
s'aperçoive que j'y serai n'ont
bizarrement environ 15 à 20 % s'est
assise stable en ce moment un les
indicateurs qu'on regarde c'est l'écart
entre le taux à long terme et le taux à
court terme et puis ça s'est rendu en
général en ce moment ça indique
peut-être une probabilité de 15 à 20
pour ça mais il ya beaucoup de risques
naturellement il ya beaucoup de risques
et on va augmenter probablement les taux
d'intérêt à plusieurs reprises un demi
point de pourcentage a dit monsieur part
aux états unis pour les prochains
meetings de 50 points de base et vont
être considérée mais encore là ça dépend
vraiment d'évolution des données puis on
va voir beaucoup plus de données dit six
mois de juin le prochain meeting après
ça en juillet monsieur de dieu merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec nous ça
fait plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit